axione aux initiatives sociales ont
remis plus de 6000 $ est devenue une
famille canadienne moyens il est temps
d'élire un gouvernement qui sera au
service de tous les canadiens un
gouvernement qui aidera la classe
moyenne a joint les deux bouts
justement nous avons demandé à plusieurs
économistes de définir la classe moyenne
on expulsait paiement le 10 % les plus
prouvé le dispensant des plus des plus
hauts revenus et tout le reste c'est la
classe moyenne sont pas les personnes
seules ça devrait en trente et soixante
mille d'alors après pour son prend les
familles avec deux travailleurs vous
allez avoir à peu près un écart entre 50
et 95 mille dollars a pris c'est savary
ça varie entre autres en fonction des
régions au pays
de plus la classe moyenne n'est plus
d'un groupe homogène selon l'économiste
françois delorme qui s'est penché sur la
question
nos résultats montrent que cette classe
moyenne là c'est oui toujours
les familles biparentales ça veut dire
deux parrains deux enfants mais aussi
les monoparentales les personnes seules
les personnes âgées les couples sans
enfants donc aujourd'hui lac quand on
dit je vais m'adresser je suis un
politicien et je m'adresse à la classe
moyenne
je m'adresse à des clientèles qui ont
des besoins très différents
vous avez des cartes de crédit j'imagine
nancy richard et rémy d'humains
travaillent tous les deux ils ont deux
enfants
ils estiment qu'ils font partie de la
classe moyenne on tombe ont séché fonds
devrait tourner autour de 100 mille
dollars par année ensemble et vous vous
considérez chaque classe moyenne
commence que vous continuez tout sauf
riches non classes moyennes c'est
vraiment la bonne catégorie nancy et
rémy sont propriétaires de leur maison à
montréal
ils ont
deux voitures et une seule carte de
crédit ils font attention à leurs
dépenses et c'est important aussi
budgété comme nous on est un parti déjà
dans le régime d'épargne-études de nos
enfants sont aussi on pense à l'avant ce
fut la même chose pour nourrir
il faut faire des choix de vie on a déjà
établi comme tout le monde on voudrait
tout avoir mais on sait qu'on peut pas
tout avoir
souvent on s'identifie à la classe
moyenne on croit en faire partie très
peu de gens vont dire à moi je fais
partie sidéré je fais partie des gens à
revenus élevés et ça d'un point de vue
politique je pense que c'est un parti
qui rentrent en parce que étant donné
qu'on veut rejoindre le plus grand
nombre de gens on va voir la pluralité
des voix
tous les économistes qui l'on a parlé
précise que le sort de la classe moyenne
loin de s'étioler s'est améliorée au
pays grâce aux politiques publiques
mais françois delorme se désole de voir
comment le concept de la classe moyenne
est galvaudé c'est comme un message qui
à kiki qui touchent à peu près tout le
monde donc et pas beaucoup de risques à
s'adresser à la classe moyenne plutôt
que de cibler nous on va aider les
familles à bas revenus a qui ont plus
que 5 enfin bref s'il faut en croire nos
spécialistes la classe moyenne est
devenu une sorte de fourre-tout pratique
pour des politiciens en quête de vote
ici catherine kovacs radio canada
montréal